I don't know I was just like at the end
of this movie should have been okay the
results are in and Ultron you are not
the [ __ ] there are no strings on me hmm
ex machina so ex machina is one of those
movies you've probably never heard of or
you saw it on a YouTube ad somewhere in
your like alright small movie next I'm
here to tell you what it's about ex
machina ultimately it's about this guy
this computer geek played by dum ha
Gleeson he wins this contest so he gets
to fly down to this dudes cabin and buy
cabin I mean insane mansion slash lab
this guy's the creator of the generic
cinematic Google because they can't call
it Google he's like alright I created
this really attractive artificial
intelligence girl so I need you to quiz
her for a few days so we can find out if
she's actually artificial intelligence
simple enough and then after that the
tension just starts building not gonna
lie this is a tension filled movie I
love that anytime there's tension in a
movie I might give it and it only builds
because these actors all of them are
great Oscar Isaac and Omaha Gleason
they're awesome
these two work really well together
right when you meet Oscar Isaac you're
like is something off about you you
don't know if he's an [ __ ] or he's
just this really reclusive eccentric guy
he's a rich dude they're always a little
weird
I was just captivated by the dialogue
nothing else is really happening at this
moment for the past looks a 2 or 3
scenes except these two talking but when
this dude when Oscar Isaac is talking
you're like yeah you're really smart I
just love listening to smart people
which is a credit to the writer of this
movie who's also the director of this
movie also noted first movie he's ever
directed how you're watching this movie
you're like I know I've seen this guy's
work before how many movies let 10 25
one singular movie and a girl who plays
the Machine the artificial intelligence
Alicia vikander we're gonna see a lot
more of her to everybody in this movie
I'm pretty sure has five more scripts on
their desk now because of this movie
seriously they're all excellent in the
movie and they can be common at so many
different angles in this movie that you
don't know what angle they're coming in
and that's half the tension right there
is you figuring out you're like alright
where's everyone coming from does anyone
have ill intent
they don't have intent I don't trust
them I don't trust you but if I don't
trust you I must trust you but I don't
really tell who who's the [ __ ] which
makes it sound like it's like clue in a
lab but it's really it's not like that
one of the bummers of this movie is for
as complex as the movie ultimately comes
across as the general overall premise is
pretty cliche I mean when you tell
someone the premises there's an
artificial intelligence and this guy is
going to quiz the artificial
intelligence to see if it's artificial
intelligence you're gonna put the
artificial intelligence under the
microscope you know right there you're
like you mean the movies gonna put
humanity under the microscope right
that's what you mean there's no two ways
about it it's not a spoiler to say it
it's just it is as obvious as obvious
convinced the execution though that's
the interesting part and the actors and
their dialogue together this movie's not
gonna be for everybody I recognize that
immediately I have seen movies people
like oh my good is so great that I'm
watching them like nice just kind of
boring that's what it is now I'm one of
the ones in the kind of slow movie going
yeah movies great however ex machina I
was intrigued by it I loved the acting
in the movie I loved the chemistry
between the actors it has slow parts for
sure but this movie uses the slow parts
to build tension I will certainly say ex
machina is definitely worth buying on
blu-ray I can see this movie doing this
I feel like I'm going to think about the
movie and the more I think about the
movie and more time passes it's gonna be
like a red wine it's gonna just get
better with time so we'll see what
happens right now I'm just telling you
it's really good excellent movie iso ex
machina have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you seen here and you
want to see more click right here to see
more